[Music]
and welcome back to another episode of
the careful boys and today we've got
alex acosta in the building hello alex
what's up what's up what's up man heard
you had a crazy life update feel free to
enter yes uh i moved into a camper
outside of my mom's house like a rv
a camper i called it an rv my mom got
mad she's like it's a camper what's the
difference i think an rv well rv you can
drive i believe okay this one you can
this is so it's a trailer basically well
you can't you can't say trailer no i
can't camper sounds better but
cause cause you know how sometimes they
have those like retirement center
trailer parks right
where like that's what you live in it's
like
mine does so i have it has two wheels
because it has like a jack that you can
drive it around and stuff like that so
is it one of those like
like what do you call it like those air
streams or something where you can hook
up to your yeah so basically what it
what it is it's connected to the power
and the water
uh like the main house so like i have
full electricity i have full water
um i do have to like the shower there's
like separate tanks for like the shower
and the sink water and then a separate
tank for like the when i go bathroom how
big is this wait you moved into a camper
that's connected to the home so you
moved out of a home to move into a
camper yeah so like the guy i was living
at uh i was living at a house in like
over in san gabriel and the guy was
starting to like just become too much
like they were harassed me he claimed
that my one single fan was raising the
bill 300 bucks
not a fan just like a normal fan and i
haven't been a vornado i i've been there
for like almost like four and a half
years
and like you know we would get these new
people in and all that stuff like that
but i had done the same thing i had my
little portable ac unit because they
never turned on the ac in the house in
the in the winter or in the summer oh i
know the types so in the summer the room
because my ac unit has like a
temperature thing on it it used to get
like 118 degrees in my room specifically
like upstairs damn
you know all the rooms were illegal so
they had like four built illegal built
rooms in the house
uh the chinese guy owns this place
and uh
you guys say yes man yeah what the [ __ ]
i did
come on i said
what's it called and so yeah so just
randomly out of nowhere like this fool
just started like harass me like like
two months before i left like oh the
electricity bill was higher so i need
you to give me 80 bucks i was like the
[ __ ] because my utilities are included
like on the contract sign and everything
like that utilities are included so i
come in so there's illegal rooms but
there's still contracts exactly yeah
hilarious we were only allowed to pay
our rent in cash they never wanted like
direct deposited or checks or anything
like that gv baby yeah yeah but toadies
are included though including
electricity
yeah dude
do you know do you know how many bitcoin
miners i could pack in that [ __ ]
place oh dude trust me i there were some
times because he used to like because he
was from china and he would have like
his like family come but sometimes he
used to divide the kitchen so i would
come home and there'd be a curtain and
literally people sleeping on little
mattresses oh [ __ ] i'm not even
exaggerating or making it up yeah there
were people sleeping there um and he
used to have like four people staying in
his room
and it was just like what the [ __ ]
that's why the internet was so shitty
because there was so much people in the
house sometimes crazy that you go from
that and now you're in the camp you're
like this is the [ __ ] life
okay now you got privacy
no but he was trying to charge me like
crazy and then like he had me sign this
contract like in march i'm gonna start
charging you utilities this was in
january i'm like all right whatever
that's more than a month whatever
whatever 50 bucks but then like a week
pass and then he's like all right so you
owe me uh 80 bucks for december and 60
bucks for january well why do you have
to do it in a chinese accent though bro
yeah is that chinese you were you were
doing it i saw it can't be using your
fingers like this all pro oh i saw what
you were doing what am i supposed to do
hey so you owe me mo [ __ ] a 30 buck
that's better do it like that yeah
that's the south province yeah
but now so you try to do that [ __ ] so i
left right i said [ __ ] you i'm not
paying you you you literally telling me
sign saying march but now you're asking
me for december
so mom's like yo i got a camper
or we have the camper just stay in that
she's like if you need to come in the
house obviously you can come in the
house so like when i poo i go into the
house because that toilet toilet's
really small but yeah it is i'm like i'm
leaving this camper i'm like yo where's
the orientation of that versus where the
house is like literally like it's in the
driveway it's in the driveway
yeah so you're sleeping slanted always
no no he's on that part of the driveway
no they have like uh they have like uh
like things to kind of balance it out
but the bed is like a tempur-pedic bed
oh bro i envy them dude [ __ ] out of you
right now as an ac
we have like mesh routers all around so
i have one in there so like my
internet's high speed ask you i'm like
do you need to be like hard lined in
yeah to get good gameplay yeah so like
the internet in there is high speed i
have a tv that's mounted
how big is it yeah yeah i stream in
there now so i'm able to stream again
because the internet's good
they have like a little like 24 hours in
there bless you but like i was like it's
like not even as big as my computer
monitoring yeah
if i get a trailer can i park it at one
of your guys's place and come through we
can be trailing we're gonna have trailer
buds hey but honestly like what did we
start a trailer park
so my mom was like telling me all about
jk trailer parts and like they have
those big silver ones i think those ones
like the airstream yeah yeah those are
the same like now living in like this
camper like because it has a closet for
my stuff and it's not big you know but i
you know i have a closet i have a full
sink i have a stove bathroom shower
everything in it
and then like they're selling a bunch of
land out there i'm like damn why don't
you buy some land let's do it bro
and then oh damn that's a great you just
gave me a [ __ ] genius idea honestly
if i didn't have a wife it's exactly how
i would like me too yeah now so now my
dad lives like this like even then like
like at my old spot i was like i never
want to bring girls over there because
it's so like you know why do you take
her to the trailer though yeah but i'll
take it to the camper like that they
shake all right you know what though
these days that shit's like you're
minimalist you're but there's a name
cool man yeah man it's cool being a
[ __ ] gypsy now domicile man yeah
you're a digital nomad that's my thing
is guys can live [ __ ] anywhere dude
we don't give a [ __ ] i could live in a
storage container
yeah you know what a man guys can do
that [ __ ] watch i'll show you that's
that's the camper oh sick can we show
that can we show the audience yeah it's
just off my
can kind of see it in the ears
oh dude it's a little vintage yeah it's
a little yeah it's an old school it's
like i think it was in made in or it's
like in the from the 70s my mom and
steph that bought it they like revenge
right like reamped it redid the shower
everything like that how much do you
think this is on some dream [ __ ] to be
honest how much do you think you could
get it for like
like how much you joe's gonna buy it
from you i want one you wanna you wanna
have an appraiser come back i have to
ask my mom no no i don't i don't wanna
buy it from you i'm just saying like
like something like this honestly i
think they picked it up i'm not lying i
think for like 3 500 bucks
don't [ __ ] crazy what
that's kind of like my stepdad's a
handyman so we kind of just fixed it up
oh bro
yesterday on offer up there's one
very similar to that but the door's a
little [ __ ] up hollowed out thousand
bucks a thousand dollars yeah like i
said don't like the thing is you can fix
some shits for the bathroom right you
have to there's like this whole
mechanism you put a hose on it you know
we put it by the like trees and then you
pull it out it drains like the shower
and sink water and like every like two
three weeks you have to drain out like
the bathroom so like it's like a whole
different process it smells but
honestly i'm like
i was telling my mom this i'm like
honestly like whenever if i get some
money i might just think about buying
some land get a nice little like air
streamer like why not those those things
are way bigger than what i'm living in
right now and i have enough space for me
and like sometimes my sister and my mom
will just come in and hang out with me
and chill in there there's enough room
we bring my big old dog in there i'm
like this is i like this you see the
ones where the the wall like pushes out
yeah exactly for the bed like opens the
whole thing they have a little patio
today's video is brought to you by
masterworks masterworks enables anyone
to become a shareholder in legendary
artworks from the likes of picasso
banksy and basquiat to just name a few
whereas in the past you needed millions
for that level of art so now anyone can
invest with masterworks here's some
reasons why masterworks is worth the
investment contemporary art prices
outpace the s p 500s total return from
1995 to 2020 by
164 percent contemporary art price has a
price depreciation of 23
on average when inflation is above 3
contemporary art prices have appreciated
14
annually on average from 1995 to 2020.
unlike some assets which could be
printed out of thin air like that guy
there's only a very limited supply of
this asset and as time progresses the
supply will only continue to become more
scarce making it more sought after you
see this is a one-of-a-kind bobby lee
original
with my sriracha stains and it was a
memorable video so diversify your
portfolio with an asset that actually
performs better when inflation is high
and our listeners get to skip the wait
list just go to masterworks dot are
slash record see important regulations
and disclosures at masterworks dot io cd
again that's masterworks dot art slash
record so in vegas right they have this
uh it's like a rv community and you can
rent out a lot or buy a lot right and
then these lots they got the hookup and
all that stuff but they also have like a
um like a storage and a shed but this
lot would probably be like i don't know
like 50 grand or something right
and it's all like gated it looks nice
and then the the people that live there
they have those like trailers that that
look like they cost a hundred grand or
whatever and it's like they look like
huge massive and then um there's a
community center in the middle with a
jacuzzi pool spa movie theater and then
like all this stuff you can pool above
ground please be above ground no it's
it's a doughboy
to me it looks like like a resort or
motel or like not like a yeah like a
hotel or something where like like when
you know everything there's a thing in
the middle where you could go there's a
community center [ __ ] like that right
and i was like [ __ ] dude that looks
really fun
um because then i can get that spot and
just get a camper and then come down to
jk
when i film and then drive right back
yeah knowing you're gonna at least spend
30 to 40 grand on a camper i'm looking
up these bad boys right now and it's
like yeah the air streams like the all
silver ones those ones are the ones that
are more expensive
but like i would do kind of like yeah
they're sick as [ __ ] and they look
really nice they're really nice on the
inside yeah but
now nowadays that i've been doing this
i'm like i kind of like this because
it's like
it's smaller it's not too big i feel
like as i've gotten older the idea of
having a huge house for me at least is
kind of just like that's so much
cleaning i'm just like just random [ __ ]
happens you're like why the [ __ ] isn't
the wall unit on right now like it's
flickering why what's going on with it
do they have to call guys i like i'm
loving it you know at first i was kind
of just like i wonder how this would go
my mom's like you can come in the house
stay there for like a week because they
have an extra room in the house
but after that first week i'm like yo
it's kind of cool
what if we just buy a whole trailer park
right kick out all the residents there
the senior citizens and the people that
are poor just kick them the [ __ ] out
gentrify bro oh we on the new management
now boys
[Laughter]
[ __ ] kick them all out right and then
we clean it up and we just make it our
jk haven how about that that would be
great i would love it that would be cool
but then we have to stack them and
reorient them
that's cool
when i was growing up my friend he had
he lived in a trailer park and like they
had a trailer and it's one of those like
deceiving ones where it looked small but
it was a three-bedroom full kitchen full
living room three-bedroom trailer yeah i
was it was surprising it was like a
harry potter tent
it was it was big i was surprised but
it's also like in a shitty ass
neighborhood and stuff but
yeah it's it's been really [ __ ] cool
you know where that atlantic movie
theater was right there yeah um that
used to be a big trailer park my friend
lived there and then you know
they got cleaned the [ __ ] out and then
they built a [ __ ] movie theater
yeah they just they just move those
things right see like a different
place i don't know i think the rest of
it
no it has
wheels from learning what it is like for
like those rv parks and stuff like or
the trailer parks is that you can buy
your own like trailer house or whatever
like that but then you still have to pay
like for your spot yeah it's like if you
move in there so no matter what you're
still going to pay like 1200 bucks a
month just to be on that spot 1200 a
month yeah but you know how expensive la
is i was looking at trailer parks and um
you know the ones that look like actual
homes but they're just like rectangle
yeah they're stuck right
that [ __ ] was a quarter mil
i was like what the [ __ ] dude that [ __ ]
should be no more than a hundred
thousand at least there's no housing
bubble
i know right good god dude when that
thing pops it's gonna be wild
yeah so i think the move is is like
especially where i'm at now i'm over in
upland san bernardino area they have a
bunch of land like for sale like little
spots of land to like 300 000 400 000
and just get yourself like a little
camper and
you're [ __ ] good to go you're getting
a thousand for land that's it huh
how much land you get for and just to
play the campaign
i'm going off of one example that's buy
our house so that that that spot was 300
000 but it was a it was big it was like
a lot of you know you could put a huge
house and like a lot of like backyard
you guys seen this [ __ ] where you can
like live at disney now what what
they're building out like a [ __ ]
community and you could live there isn't
that for like seniors or something like
that well no they're building a new one
now too they had yeah they had the old
one then they're building a new one out
too in anaheim like by disneyland i
think it's in in world oh but it's like
because there's so many acres there it's
like a disney community but they're
doing like a disney community but
they're also gonna have like story
themes inside of it so there's like
active story [ __ ] going on inside of
your own community be [ __ ] weird huh
i love it that would be sick as well
before it'd be it could be fun it could
be could be i like it because it'll
attract all the crazy people and take
them there away from us okay i see and
then just and then you just one bomb
will solve it all the way well you're
talking about the i know you're talking
about each other you're talking about
the disney carnies right yeah like the
people who were there too much yeah the
disney people oh they have like nothing
but pins covering their whole face
it's a little wild would you be able to
walk out into the park like that i think
so holy [ __ ] that's a pretty cool side
of disney it's like for people who never
have to leave disneyland it's not
necessarily inside disney world but
it'll be like connected where you can
take like a tram or some [ __ ] like that
imagine inside disney world though by
like the cars section or some [ __ ] like
that that'd be sick
that was kind of fresh that is kind of
cool that'd be dope if you just get like
a [ __ ] baby rv and you're just one of
the autopia cars
but no one can ride yours a kid's
driving you around every day
oh yeah you're just in it just living in
it there's so many sick ass places to
live though like i think when you get to
our age right you get to see
all the adult fun [ __ ] right because
like when you're younger you just kind
of like you just live where your parents
choose what about van life you think you
do van life
uh i tried it like i rented a i worked
with the van company and then we were
out in colorado for a couple weeks
and uh one thing would be the showers
so we were in the middle of winter so it
was [ __ ] hard so we'll be like every
five days we get a shower or something
so like yeah that's pretty rough it's
pretty rough and it was like a [ __ ]
van full of four dudes you know so like
yeah i was at my neighbor's house
recently and
uh they live like so we have like a
bunch of lakes in our community and they
live on the lake and so you look through
the backyard there's just this [ __ ]
lake there and they have like this um
like they can just take a boat out
and they're like yeah let us know you
can use the boat whenever you want and
it's like dude how the [ __ ] did i get to
a point in my life where i have
neighbors who have boats and i can go to
use their boat that's pretty crazy i
feel like i'm like 57 years old and i'm
like retired you made it dude i [ __ ]
did it dude you [ __ ] ate it
but i didn't sell any crypto to get my
place either so that'll be that'll be
fun but um but no but having having
access to boating and [ __ ] and like
having a fake that's another level of
it's crazy it's crazy that's only for
like older people or if you live in like
well you can't get that in california
because like like i was talking about
you [ __ ] spend 300 000 on land yeah
that's true and dirt and that's cheap
here too that's what's crazy about it
have you ever heard of canyon lake
that sounds familiar where's that it's
so like by lake elsinore there's a city
called canyon lake and it's it's pretty
much like in this whole country it's the
biggest
private community
so you have to like it's it's a gated
city like the whole place what and it
surrounds like this actual lake and it's
got houses and it has like uh all the
amenities and stores you need you never
have to leave but like nobody ever
[ __ ] goes there or knows about it
look up canyon lake and look how
freaking unreal realistically beautiful
it is and it's like a best kept secret
no
so i got into the deep dive of like
canyon lake because i was like what the
hell is this so that i went to they have
like a community youtube where like
every week they make a youtube video
announce what's going on in the city and
i started watching them and i was like
like a city hall meeting yeah i felt
like i was infiltrating it all the
announcements and there's two kenyan
leagues there's like one in california
and one like somewhere else but what the
whole place is just put my my camper
like right here so it's a it's it's a
dam it's a community and a dam it's like
a yeah it's like a manufactured city
they built around this this like lake
and you have to like because the reason
i found out about is i was trying to buy
this thing on offer up and the guy lived
in canyon lake and he was like oh are
you not a resident cause like i have my
search thing all weird so i can't talk
to non-residents he's like please don't
tell anybody right so he was like oh
i'll have to i'll have to meet you
outside the gate and i was like what
like your [ __ ] cul-de-sac and he's
like no it's canyon lake i was like what
the [ __ ] does that mean he's like oh
that's candy lane
you're not a part of us
is really [ __ ] weird what keeps you
in cali
what's that what keeps you in cali
businesses that i have okay yeah that's
the only thing yeah how come you never
talk about your own businesses to
promote it he has photo studios where a
lot of only fans come in and jack
themselves off
no
like it's artistic it's a lot of cool
[ __ ] though it's a good place to beat
off of her yeah
i'm just [ __ ] looking up airstreams
now and they're sick
like something like that on a piece of
land just a little bit on a piece of
land you have some electric hookup some
water hookup and you're all set move to
vegas live like a [ __ ] king
with a piece of land that's cheaper yeah
and you can go here this that that's my
goal is i want to get land get one of
these and that's where i'm going that
was probably be more expensive than the
land that you get in vegas
probably yeah because these ones
something like this is these can range
from like i think this is a hundred
thousand yeah sixty to like a hundred
thousand depending on the size but look
at that's the inside okay so it's like
yeah that's basically what i'm living in
right you can view view floor plans wow
custom now now the video's over
[Music]
[Music]